foreign
I'm product manager at Google Cloud
in this video we'll introduce risk
scoring with attack path simulations a
capability in security Command Center
security Command Center provides you
with sophisticated and detailed insights
on your security posture including asset
visibility misconfigurations
vulnerabilities detection of malicious
activity compliance and more
we want to provide you with even further
capabilities we want to enable you to
identify what findings create the most
risk to your environment in terms of
exposing your resources towards
potential attackers
to quantify how exposed your specific
environment is to potential attacks and
track and visualize how you improve over
time
to take targeted actions what to address
first second and third in order to be
the most effective every day
providing these capabilities are about
attack paths combining the insights on
each specific finding with the context
your infrastructure your IAM
relationships between resources and
systems Etc
let me provide some examples
the finding that has a high severity
score
might be very hard to reach as it is
deep down in the architecture
a finding might be easy to reach but not
related to your high value resources
instead you might have two lower
severity findings that in combination
creates the biggest exposure or it might
be that access Rights created by one
team in combination with some new
finding in another team's infrastructure
together create a highway to some high
value resources
introducing attack pod simulations in
security Command Center the concept
consists of three steps model generation
attack part simulations and insights on
exposures and mitigations
starting with model generation
based on your specific environment your
resources relationship between resources
configurations Etc
a big graph is created
these graphs which we call models are
representations of your environment
including all the relationships Etc
this is all automated and requires no
agents
SEC then simulates attacks where virtual
attackers try everything and anything on
your model to reach and compromise your
high value resources
the simulations enable insights on all
potential paths from the attacker to
your high value resources
what are the paths of least resistance
to those high value resources and what
security findings are enabling these
paths
quantification of how exposed your
resources are to potential attacks and
what to address first second and third
to be the most effective
note that all simulations are conducted
on models which means that the
simulations that does not interfere with
your live environment and you can
conduct what-if scenarios make tests
before implementation and include both
knowns and unknowns in the analysis
let's dig into more details here's an
example attack path
to the very left there is the attacker
in the simulations
in this case an external attacker is
simulated but you can also simulate
insiders and the attackers can have more
or less capabilities to represent
everything from an apt to a script Kitty
in the simulations the attacker tries
everything and anything to reach your
high value resources
the attack logic is built into the tool
the simulations leverages insights on
each specific node and Edge including
Network relations IAM configurations
misconfigurations vulnerabilities Etc
and provides insights into how an
attacker can Traverse your network to
reach and compromise your valued
resources
in this example we see that the critical
path meaning the path of least
resistance is leveraging a specific cve
that in combination with access rights
enable the attacker to assume a service
account and in turn perform action on a
bigquery table with valuable data
addressing this specific CV is thus key
use cases for attack pod simulations are
vast from vulnerability and posture
management to seize a risk management
and progress tracking to threat
management and incident response and
devsecops empowering devops teams to
name a few
in this video Let's now dig into the use
case of findings prioritization
what we want to do is to identify what
findings create the most risk to your
organization
the automated attack part simulations
enable you to do exactly this running
simulations in the background
identifying all potential parts to your
valuable resources
and providing attack exposure scores on
findings based on to what extent each
finding contributes to exposing valuable
resources
this enables your team to distill which
findings to focus on
foreign